there's renewed hope this morning that
the highly-anticipated summit between
President Trump and North Korean leader
Kim jong-un may still happen the leaders
of North and South Korea held a surprise
meeting this morning at the border it
comes after president Trump's signaled
Friday that the canceled meeting could
still happen next month mola Lengai is
at the White House this morning where
the president is spending the holiday
weekend mola good morning good morning
the on-again off-again summit between
President Trump and the North Korean
leader took yet another turn yesterday
speaking to reporters outside the White
House President Trump used one of his
favorite phrases to reveal that a
meeting he cancelled less than 24 hours
before may go on as planned
we'll see what happens it could even be
that well before leaving the White House
Friday president Trump told reporters
the discussions with North Korea about a
possible meeting had resumed that
statement issued by North Korea's first
vice minister of foreign affairs Kim
kye-gwan praised president Trump's bold
decision to agree to the historic
meeting and expressed the North's
sincere and active efforts to end the
relations of hostility that have lasted
for decades the president's not just
looking to have a meeting he's not
looking for just a cheap political stunt
he wants to get something that's a long
lasting and actual real solutions press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders said
the White House was looking for a
meeting that could produce results and
if the North Korean overtures were
serious the president would be ready
we're always gonna be prepared and if
the meeting takes place on June 12th
we'll be ready if it takes place on July
12th we'll be ready a planning trip to
Singapore led by deputy chief of staff
Jo Hagan also appears to be in question
early Friday the deputy press secretary
Hogan Gidley said he couldn't comment on
whether preparations would go forward
there are no plans for that right now
the White House now says it will send a
team to Singapore for summit planning if
it can secure guarantees that the North
Koreans will attend they've skipped out
before and the White House doesn't want
to be stood up twice defense our
James Madison at are back at it and
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo could be
dispatched for more talks if needed
Anthony mola legi at the White House
thanks